(upbeat music)
- Hello, my name is Leslea Hlusko.
I'm an associate professor
here in the Department
of Integrative Biology,
and it is my distinct honor
to get to introduce Professor
Nina Jablonski today.
For those of you who were able
to attend her talk yesterday,
you've heard of her
academic accomplishments.
She did her undergraduate
work at Bryn Mawr.
She got her PhD from the
University of Washington.
She then became an anatomy instructor
at the University of Hong Kong.
She was a lecturer at the
University of Western Australia,
and the a curator of anthropology
at the California Academy of Sciences,
and then served for a while as the head
of the Department of Anthropology
at Penn State University,
where she now has the luxury of just being
a full professor, and
all that comes with that.
She's had numerous research grants,
support that came from the
National Science Foundation,
The Wallenberg Foundation,
the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation,
and the Rockefeller Foundation.
And her accolades include,
some of the most recently,
membership in the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences,
among many, many others.
So as you know, from this lecture series,
she is well-known for
her work on the evolution
of human skin color, and is deeply admired
for her talent in conveying
this excellent research
to the public.
But she is also highly
respected to those of us
in academia for her meticulous
paleontological research
in Asia and eastern Africa.
And it is this less famous
side of her research
over the years that had initially brought
the two of us together.
Now, all of us in this
room, if we're lucky,
we have a small handful
of people who have served
as an inspiration or
role model in our lives,
people who we hold up as
our intellectual heroes.
Nina is mine.
We first met years ago when
I was a graduate student
studying baboon teeth,
and she graciously gave me
some of her time, and even gave me a copy
of a beautiful monograph
that she had edited
about these magnificent animals.
And I remember clutching
that book to my chest
with pride and excitement
the whole way home that day.
So Nina has continued
over the intervening years
to be my validation and inspiration,
and her opinion has
always mattered more to me
than that of anyone else.
But more than that, for
all of us in academia,
her research and outreach efforts
on the evolutionary history
and importance of skin color
variation is a beautiful
inspiration to follow.
So Nina, thank you for
being a shining light
in our discipline, and thank you so much
for spending this week
with us in Berkeley.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Leslea for that beautiful
and generous introduction.
Thank you to the Hitchcock
lecture committee,
of which there are at least
a few representatives here,
for their gracious and
generous invitation,
and for really making possible
several wonderful days
of intellectual feasting on my part
with accomplished faculty and students.
Studying human skin and skin color
has been one of the most
rewarding possible adventures
that I think any scholar could have.
From our early studies of the
evolution of skin pigmentation
many research programs have flowed.
In short, we can understand human skin
really quite simply.
The skin pigmentation that
we see so beautifully arrayed
in a geographic pattern is not random.
It evolved as the product
of natural selection.
86% of variation in the skin color
of indigenous peoples can be explained
by variation in ultraviolet radiation.
So we have, in human skin,
a beautiful example of evolution
acting on the human body.
And we understand that skin pigmentation
is an evolutionary compromise
between the demands
of protecting against very
strong solar ultraviolet
radiation at the equator
and the equally important demands
of being able to continue to produce
vitamin D in the skin,
and I will advance today other arguments,
but continue to produce
vitamin D in the skin
under conditions of low
ultraviolet radiation
closer to the poles.
In the terms of evolutionary biology,
what we have here are two clines.
And in the intermediate
zone here and here,
we find lots of people of
intermediate pigmentation
who are able to gain and lose pigmentation
season to season through tanning.
We now recognize not only
this phenotypic pattern,
the appearance, but we understand a lot
of the genetic architecture.
Today I want to talk more about
what this means.
A few decades ago, the
Brazilian artist Angelika Dass
started to compile what she
called a chromatic inventory
of her fellow Brazilian citizens,
people who came in every
range of sepia coloration.
She wanted people to appreciate
just how similar we were,
how much our colors graded
beautifully into one another,
that there was no discontinuity
in the colors of humanity.
And so today what I
want to do is to develop
more of our own as well as
that of others' research
on the meaning of skin color,
what it means to us as social organisms,
as social primates,
and what it means to us
with respect to our health.
It's important to recognize,
when we think about the social
meaning of skin color today, often we use
the term colorblind, or
we should be colorblind.
Well, from the literal
perspective, we can't
because we as catarrhine
primates as monkeys and apes
are endowed with superb
trichromatic color vision
that allows us to see
beautiful richness of color
in very high definition.
So, we notice color.
We can't help but notice color
because of our trichromatic color vision.
So that's really important.
We're visually oriented animals.
The color of our fellow human beings,
the shape of their bodies,
all of these physical
features are important to us
because we are visually oriented animals.
So that's an important
thing to think about
from a cognitive behavioral perspective.
How did people start
interacting with one another,
people who had different skin colors,
in the course of human history?
We don't know a lot about
these early interactions.
Some of the best written and
artistic records that we have
actually come from Ancient Egypt.
We know that there were
extensive interactions
at many times in Egyptian history,
extensive interactions between peoples
in the upper and lower Nile.
Peoples who were mostly
very darkly pigmented
and moderately pigmented
or quite lightly pigmented
in the north.
The salutary message from
all of these interactions
is that trade occurred.
There were lots of diplomatic
exchanges, artistic exchanges.
And although there were
conflicts and there was warfare,
these were not on the basis
of any color distinction,
but rather of inequities of resources
or trade imbalances and other
various kinds of disagreements
that might exist sort
of any polities in time.
Very importantly, the idea of
calling another group
other, because of color,
did not exist, to our knowledge.
This is not to say that we didn't engage
in what Michael Omi
and many other scholars
have called the process of othering.
The process of racial formation.
If we go back again in ancient history
to look at the interaction
between the Greeks
and the Persians, for instance,
the Greeks refer to the
Persians as barbarians.
They were distinctly
defined by their language,
by their dress, and
their costumes as other,
and as barbarians, in a negative sense.
The category of other
existed, although it was not
associated with skin color.
When we think about coming
into the more modern
Western scientific tradition
and how people started
to think about human diversity,
it's not inappropriate to pick
up the story with Linnaeus,
because he was one of the first,
albeit not the very first, to
think about human variation
and how we might classify it.
Now, what's really interesting
and incredibly important
to remember is that for Linnaeus,
and many other European
scholars at the time,
there was no personal
experience with people
in foreign countries outside of Europe.
Many people, many naturalists, historians,
like Linnaeus and others,
basically stayed at home.
I mean, travel was logistically difficult,
plus they enjoyed the comforts
of their life at home,
and they relied, instead, on information,
biological samples,
and sort of travel logs
that came to them via a series of sources
often from Portuguese,
French, Italian explorers.
So people like Linnaeus
got biological specimens,
not so much of primates and humans,
although he did a few primates.
But they learned about human
variation from stories,
second, third, and often fourth-hand.
And when Linnaeus turned
his attention to classifying
humans, initially he
classified them very simply.
Four groups, Europeans,
Americans, Asians, and Africans,
separated by what he saw
as the cardinal distinction
of skin color, white, red, brown, black.
No hierarchy, just a list.
What happens in the intervening years?
Here we are, middle of
the 18th century, 1748.
1758, only 10 years later,
his description of variation
in humans is much longer,
and I've only given a little digest here.
Significantly, we have the same groups
and the skin colors
again, red for Americans,
white for Europeans, brown for Asians,
black for Africans.
But we also have these other words,
choleric, sanguineus,
melancholicus, phlegmanticus,
describing temperament and behavior.
And here, Linnaeus is really referencing
Hippocrates, Herodotus, and other scholars
of Ancient Greece who wrote extensively
on human temperaments being formed
by the intensity of the
sun and their environment.
Are people experiencing too
much heat, too much cold,
too much moisture?
Their temperament, their
behavior would be formed
by their environment.
And what's remarkable
here is that Linnaeus,
the systematist of the natural world,
who is describing mosses and
monkeys in a most objective,
what we would called scientific way,
is here describing humans
according to their temperament.
And this heralds of
different treatment of humans
that we see elaborated in various ways
in the coming decades.
The middle 18th century
is the seething hotbed
of intellectual thought
about human diversity.
Scholars throughout the
western intellectual tradition
are trying to understand what does it mean
when people look different?
Are these people all from one source?
Are they separate creations?
Where did this diversity come from?
And what does it mean with
respect to people's cultures,
their capacity for civilization?
And this is where we
come to the work of many
important philosophers, but
I'm singling out here today
Immanuel Kant, because
Kant holds a special place
in the history of philosophy
and critical thought.
He is lionized, rightly, for many
of his philosophical writings.
But early in his career,
Kant thought deeply
about human diversity.
He was trying to understand
why do people seem to have
different predilections for
behaving in certain ways
to be civilized, different
abilities to develop
higher modes of thought.
And so in a series of writings,
beginning in 1775 and concluding in 1788,
he is writing on the
subject of human diversity,
something that very few people recognized.
And what he does is he formally constructs
four races of humans,
and he is the first to
formally use that term.
He uses the German noun
(speaking in foreign language),
not race, but these are formal categories.
And very significantly,
he differs from Linnaeus,
because these aren't just four groups.
These are four groups that are ordered
in the order of their
potential for civilization,
their potential for
developing higher thoughts,
for being able to use reasoning.
And very importantly, for Kant,
these categories were immutable.
And once a particular group,
for instance the Negro race
as he defined it here, or the Hunish race,
once they developed a certain
series of morphological
characteristics, including color,
that was an irreversible pathway.
So he had a very rigid idea,
as well as a hierarchical notion
of how humans were arrayed.
And famously, Kant almost never
left his own sitting room.
So Kant got information
from many of these rich,
by then very rich travelers' tales,
and he distilled it in his own way.
And he was joined in this,
slightly earlier in time,
by the Scottish philosopher David Hume.
Hume made less thorough
investigations of human diversity,
but when you read Hume's
writings, one is left in no doubt
that he knew who was superior.
"There was never a civilized
nation of any complexion
"other than white."
So, even though there were many
influential, quite influential detractors
in the mid-18th century to Kant and Hume,
why did this idea,
this notion of human races in a hierarchy,
immutable, unmixable,
how did this view come
to have such popularity
to this day?
Races for Kant and Hume were physically
and culturally distinct from one another,
and there was no doubt in
either of these man's minds
that the so-called
White race was superior.
This ascendancy we can now
look at through the richness
of history as being
completely understandable.
Both of these people were highly regarded.
One of the things I'm
most interested in is
who's managing reputations.
In the days before software companies
were managing reputations,
who managed reputations?
Basically, some scholars
were highly regarded,
their works were widely circulated,
in particular salons.
The information about
them was communicated
from one scholar to
another by correspondence.
People, these books, their
books became widely distributed,
largely on the basis of personal circles
of influence to the extent that these two,
David Hume and Immanuel
Kant, in their lifetimes,
became very, very highly regarded
and their books were widely
distributed and translated.
Their writings were taken up
by other prominent scholars
and by statesmen, so that you
have politicians including
politicians in the nascent
colonies and the United States
reading these works, as well.
And we must bring in
economics at this time.
This transatlantic slave
trade is expanding.
There is pressure, especially in England,
to lessen or do away with the slave trade,
but there is tremendous,
tremendous support
from mercantile interests
in Europe to continue
to promote it, to grow it
in whatever way is possible.
This is where we begin to
see tremendously interesting,
and in retrospect nefarious
and tragic alliances
between commercial mercantile interests,
philosophers, and some
very, very bad theology.
By the middle 19th
century, tracts like this,
The Biblical Defence of Slavery,
The Origin, History, and
Fortunes of the Negro Race,
this is just one of many tracts
that purport to use biblical sources
to prove the inferiority of black people,
especially darkly pigmented
people from Africa.
So what we see, between
the middle of the 18th
and the middle of the 19th
century is the imperfect storm
of forces, of economic, philosophical,
and theological forces, and I
want to say quasi-theological
forces, because there's
nothing in the Bible
that talks about discrimination
according to color.
Stories about the curse of Ham
are based on interpretations
that are very much culturally
influenced interpretations
of the Old Testament.
So in this century,
between the mid-1700s and mid-1800s,
we have this maelstrom of forces,
not only demonstrating,
proving the existence of races,
proving the immutability of races,
but also proving the inferiority
of the so-called Negro race.
And further, in some of these
biblical defenses of slavery,
proving that Negros were
only fit for slavery,
they were fit for serving others,
and that their biology dictated this.
This was a wild time.
And we can only recognize now how much
we were being manipulated.
The boxes basically have text in them
showing how the progress
from this racial ideation
to the creation of racial stereotypes
to what I call color memes,
in the Richard Dawkins sense
of a culturally transmitted
idea, that seems,
that acts like a genetic trait.
Color-coded race concepts
become color memes
that are stereotypes.
And this lays the clear psychosocial
template for racism.
So by the mid-19th century,
we have color-based racism
as the reality in the United States
and in many other countries.
This reality has been constructed in a way
that is completely understandable,
but in a way that most
people don't recognize.
And certainly in a way
that most schoolchildren
in the United States are taught about.
When we look at the cost,
the human cost of the slave trade,
we begin to recognize
what is involved here.
Nearly 13 million people
involved in the slave trade,
and from a social perspective, tremendous,
tremendous disengagement
of uprooting of peoples
from equatorial West Africa, primarily,
into Europe, thence to the Caribbean,
sometimes directly to South America,
and then a smaller
fraction to North America.
Nearly 13 million
people, and significantly
involuntary migration, the
largest influx of people
ever to come into the United States.
And here we transit to our
biology and health considerations
moving people from one
solar regime to another.
In many cases, moving people
from a very, very sunny place
to a less sunny place.
What consequence is this
going to have for health?
And further, what consequence
are other migrations going to have,
voluntary migrations to this day,
what are they having,
what impact are they having on health.
And further, what impact
is urbanization having?
As anthropologists, we tend to think
that sort of the world stopped
maybe at the beginning,
of the introduction of agriculture.
That all sort of important
things in sort of human evolution
stopped at that time.
I would advance to you that
some of the most important
biological changes started then.
Because as a result of mass
migrations made possible
by rapid modes of movement,
ships then planes,
people able to move dozens
of degrees of latitude
in hours instead of
weeks, or in a few days
instead of over many
generations or lifetimes,
that this physical movement of people,
as well as the concentration
of people in cities,
from fairly modest cities,
seven and 8000 years ago,
to the mega cities of the world today.
And a prospect in 20 years of 70%
of the world's population being in cities.
This is such a dramatic
departure from anything
previously in human evolution.
And today I want to talk about
specifically the consequences
for our relationship with the sun.
Where are we today?
We are in a very nice building,
far away from the sun.
And most of us have spent most of today
outside of the sun.
This is a great departure from
what even perhaps our parents
or certainly our grandparents
or great-grandparents
might have done.
People who toiled in the
fields or worked out-of-doors
or at least walked to and from work,
if they lived in cities.
These are enormous forces
of modern evolution
acting on the human body.
If we look at just some recent
human voluntary migration,
so we're not talking about the
mass involuntary migrations
of the transatlantic slave trade,
but rather just a sampling
of some of the more dramatic
migrations, long distances
often involving people
going from areas with very
low ultraviolet radiation
to high and vice versa, some
extremely long distance ones
involving great shifts from high to low
or low to high UV.
We think we're very clever
that we can undertake
these mass movements.
It is fantastically technologically superb
that we're able to undertake this,
that people can move around
freely over the surface
of the Earth's surface.
And we have the hubris to
think that we can somehow
overcome it or that it
doesn't really matter to us
as biological organisms,
because we're so clever.
Well, we're not.
Because there are some considerations,
some biological considerations
that we haven't given
full credence to.
Recall that human behavior in prehistory
was very different.
We didn't travel very much
during individual lifetimes.
Certainly people would, at various times,
pursue prey, animals,
that would be migrating
and they would go after them.
But there were never
sort of long distance,
or very few long distance
migrations of people.
And people during their lives would move
10 or 20 kilometers, maybe.
And they spent most of their time outside
and mostly without sewn clothing.
Again, if we only have needles showing up
in the archaeological
record, sewn clothing,
tailored clothing that
can protect the body
only in the last 20,000 years,
what are we doing before that?
Yes, we are protecting
ourselves with animal skins
and probably plant materials.
But skin is our major interface
during most of the major movements
and dispersals of human populations,
skin is our major interface
with the environment.
And we, as outside organisms,
are under varying ultraviolet regimes.
If we're living at the Equator,
the amount of variation is
less than if we're living
at this latitude or even
closer to the poles.
But variation in ultraviolet
radiation can be extreme.
And variation in solar
So our skin has adapted
to these changing regimens.
And we see biocultural adaptations.
Not only genetically driven
adaptations in skin pigmentation
but cultural adaptations,
modification of diet
and ways of procuring food
so that we can compensate
for difficulties posed by
the physical environment.
But today, holy hell,
not only are people dispersing,
but they take vacations.
Who took vacations 500 years ago?
Or 5000?
The whole concept of a
vacation is something
that our ancestors never entertained.
But today we have all sorts of ways
for getting people around.
And one of the things
that they like to do,
especially if they're in indoor jobs,
is that they like to find sunny places.
And so you have these
incredibly depigmented people
seeking out sunny places
for intense episodes of sun exposure.
What a bad idea.
So if we just look at a sampling
of 21st century vacations,
they are many and varied.
And on a college campus you
that it is spring break.
Kids are going all over the place.
People go all over the place.
And often in the wintertime,
they're seeking out sun.
Or they're seeking out some
interesting cultural experience
often in a sunny place.
So we have humans that are
moving, not only migrating
to live in a particular place,
we have them undertaking
these short, episodic vacations
so that they can enjoy leisure time
in a different environment.
And this is where we really begin to see
some of the first untoward
aspects of modern life
with respect to the skin.
The rise of intense, episodic sun exposure
and the vacation effect.
And not just solely sort
of going on vacation
to a sunny place,
but the rise in the use
of tanning facilities.
Now I realize there aren't
that many tanning facilities
in Berkeley, although I
did see one the other day
as I was walking around.
But where I live in Central Pennsylvania,
they are common.
And in many parts of this country,
they are extremely common.
People like to go there.
It feels better to them
when they get, quote,
sun on their bodies, UV on their bodies.
So without going into excruciating detail,
suffice it to say that people pay.
In the short term they
pay because they get
an uncomfortable sunburn,
but in the long term they pay
because of an increased susceptibility
to a variety of skin cancers.
And including if the
exposure is intense enough,
and the genetic architecture
of the skin is such,
episodic strong exposures
in childhood especially
can lead to the most
deadly form of skin cancer,
melanoma, which was almost unheard of
in humans before 1950.
So we have this interesting
pattern of morbidity
and sun mortality due to too
much episodic sun exposure.
But I want to spend
more time talking about
what happens on the
other side of the coin.
What happens in big cities,
where we have like in New York City here,
everybody, every color, every
shade of the sepia rainbow
represented, every possible ethnicity,
most people living indoors.
What happens?
Like in this Motorola plant in Texas
where all of the workers,
from whatever background,
spend all of their time indoors
assembling cell phones.
These individuals are
experiencing different rhythms
of nature, a different quality of nature,
a different kind of environment
than humans have ever experienced.
And we now are beginning to recognize
what health toll this is taking.
Yesterday I introduced the concept
of the vitamin D compromise,
how people throughout evolution
have developed ways of
getting enough vitamin D.
At the Equator, if you
are outdoors long enough,
even if you have the most
darkly pigmented skin,
you will be able to make ample vitamin D
to satisfy your physiological needs.
But if you spend time indoors,
a lot of time indoors,
that changes things.
If you are a lightly pigmented person,
even though you can get a
lot of vitamin D produced
in your skin in a relatively
short period of time,
if it's in the sunlight outdoors,
if you spend all of your time inside,
you have no opportunity to
make vitamin D in the skin.
So the vitamin D compromise,
as we have described it,
is a compromise that has been worked out
more or less by trial
and error by cultures
in various places over thousands of years,
whereby if you're not
getting a lot of vitamin D
from solar sources, you are
getting it from dietary sources.
And people living at
extreme high and extreme,
in both hemispheres, northern
and southern hemispheres,
have cultures that
concentrate on the harvesting
of vitamin D-rich foods.
So what happens to folks today?
The vitamin D compromise is mostly broken
because we are living indoors
in ways that I've described,
going to school, going to work.
When we do have outdoor sun exposure,
it may be in the very early morning
or in the late afternoon
when there's very little
in the way of ultraviolet
radiation in the sunlight.
So we may feel some benefit
from being out-of-doors,
but we're not deriving any benefit
from the positive side of
ultraviolet radiation exposure.
And with reduced time spent out-of-doors,
the combination of being in a city,
of having an indoor lifestyle, is,
I wouldn't want to say
a deadly combination,
but it's a combination that is inviting
chronic sickness of various kinds,
and I'm gonna talk about that.
The levels of morbidity and mortality
that can now be traced
to vitamin D deficiency,
especially chronic vitamin D
deficiency, are prodigious.
This is now a problem of
enormous and global proportions,
a significant global health problem.
It is, to some extent,
understated in this country,
but it's certainly not being understated
in many other countries,
especially in those where
a nationalized health system
is picking up most of the cost
for the vitamin D
deficiency-related diseases.
Cities, in addition to
promoting sedentism,
the atmosphere of some
cities filters out a lot
of UV, especially the short wavelengths,
ultraviolet B radiation.
The canyons that we find in many cities
effectively eliminates
sunlight from the ground level.
Indoor environments,
again, fluorescent lights
at best provide some illumination,
but provide no other benefit,
and sometimes can be, if they're too blue,
can actually stimulate our
alertness centers too much,
so it ruins our sleep patterns.
And in a great departure
from whatever we did
in prehistory, we now mostly
wear concealing clothing,
sewn clothing, mass-marketed clothing,
clothing that we change all the time
and we make into fashion statements.
Yeah, it's great, it's
part of human culture.
But, it's changed our relationship
to our physical environment completely.
And in some culture,
where concealing clothing
is religiously mandated,
the concealment is complete.
And this changes the nature
of the biological interface entirely.
The vitamin D compromise
is now also broken
because we have reduced consumption
of vitamin D-rich foods.
In many parts of the
world, vitamin D-rich fish
have been depleted from the sea.
The codfish that the Scots ate
in early history
and into the 20th century,
is now mostly depleted
from the North Atlantic
and the North Sea.
So, people are eating fish in this form,
often whitefish, often other types of fish
that have no or virtually
no vitamin D content at all.
So you might feel a little
bit noble about eating
something like this,
you know, as opposed to
a basket of McNuggets.
But there's very little virtue
involved in no vitamin D.
And for darkly pigmented people,
the vitamin D compromise,
especially in cities,
has been broken.
Because dark pigmentation,
dark pigmentation being such
a natural sunscreen, such
an excellent competitor
with photons, it absorbs all the UVB
that might have been used
to convert 70hc in your skin
to previtamin D.
Combine this with living
in low UV environments,
think about people
living in London, Boston,
or even just living
indoors most of the time,
the combination of dark pigmentation
and low UVB environments is critical
and has resulted in what we recognize now
as truly an epidemic
of vitamin D deficiency
in darkly pigmented people,
especially those of African origin.
So when we look at our model of skin,
here is, again, our epidermis
with dark pigmentation.
Here's ultraviolet B and ultraviolet A
coming from the sun.
At the Equator, there's a lot of both.
But UVB is being scattered and absorbed
by the atmospheric oxygen and ozone.
And here most UVB is being absorbed
by the beautiful eumelanin
in the pigment here
in the lower epidermis.
And then, what is happening
is that some vitamin D
formation is occurring.
So if someone is outdoors long enough,
even with this beautiful
natural sun protection,
ample vitamin D would form in the skin
to adequately meet physiological needs.
But as soon as UVB levels are lower,
as a result of change of
lifestyle or change of location
or both, all of a sudden
this dark pigmentation,
which competes for
photons, for UVB photons,
will entirely prohibit any UVB
from penetrating into the layer here
where vitamin D is formed.
So this we looked at in
an evolutionary context
was the reason that we see the evolution
of depigmentation in lineages
of Western Europeans and East Asians.
But it is one of the
reasons today that we see
vitamin D deficiency in
people of dark pigmentation,
especially, because this
beautiful sunscreen layer
is doing its job when we wish it wouldn't.
So what happens to vitamin
D production in the skin
when it's low or when people live inside?
Basically, it doesn't happen.
And we end up with people at best
that have seasonal peaks
in vitamin D levels.
In order to study this more fully,
we took our study, a clinical study,
to South Africa, a country
that I've been fascinated in
for years, because it is
a country and a region
that is one of the most lavish
and deeply historical
melting pots in the world,
where people through the
Bantu language expansions
of five to 3000 years ago have
moved into Southern Africa.
We have indigenous people who
have been in South Africa,
the sun, and Khoi peoples
for more than 70,000 years.
We have Europeans coming
almost 500 years ago.
And soon thereafter, waves
of immigrants and slaves
coming from Madagascar, Java, and India,
all converging on the western
cape of South Africa initially
and then branching out into
the rest of South Africa.
An incredible mixing pot
of cultures, languages,
and skin colors.
And I thought what better
place to look at the factors
that influence vitamin D
production than to take some
samples of healthy
young people and monitor
their vitamin D levels
throughout the year.
What we did also was we
measured levels of UVB
in the atmosphere.
So instead of relying on
indirect satellite measurements,
we actually looked at on the ground UVB.
And because our study was focused
on what was happening in the
very extreme southwest corner
occupied by Cape Town and
other polities nearby,
this area is particularly
bereft of sunlight
in the austral winter,
something that very few people appreciate.
South Africa is a big country
and there is a tremendous
gradient of ultraviolet radiation.
But the southwest corner is very low,
especially in the winter.
So what happens?
What happens to people's vitamin D levels
when you've got all of these
different kinds and colors
of people living in a
highly seasonal UVB regime?
To make a long story short,
they experienced seasonal
vitamin D deficiencies.
So this vitamin D
formation in the wintertime
disappears entirely.
People aren't eating vitamin D-rich foods.
They have very little access to them.
There's no vitamin D supplements
that most people can afford.
So they enter into these
troughs of vitamin D deficiency.
What happens?
When your doctor talks to you
about vitamin D deficiency,
they sort of wag their finger and say,
"Oh, you're going to be
susceptible to colds and flu,"
and all sorts of things.
In South Africa, that's also true.
But in South Africa, where
there's high prevalence,
still, of HIV-1 virus and high
prevalence of tuberculosis,
the stakes of infectious
disease are much higher.
So if your immune system is weakened
because of vitamin D deficiency,
you don't just get a sniffle.
You might actually contract infection
from the tuberculosis bacillus.
Or, if you're an HIV-1 carrier,
you might convert into
an active AIDS patient.
So vitamin D deficiency becomes
a much higher stakes problem.
Low winter UV leads to
extremely low vitamin D levels.
And what we found, it wasn't just low UVB,
but the fact that people stayed
indoors more in the winter.
So regardless of what
their skin color was,
the fact that they stayed indoors more
and didn't have access to the ambient UVB
when it was available
made a big difference
to their ultraviolet B exposure
and their vitamin D production.
And in a paper that we
published a few years ago
in the Proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences,
without going through a lot here,
we were able to show that
actually when we were able
to study the replication
of HIV virus outside of the body,
when we took blood samples from people,
looked at their vitamin D levels,
but also cultured their
blood to see what levels
of virus could be cultured
under different vitamin D levels,
what we found was that
HIV-1 virus proliferated
under conditions of vitamin D deficiency.
So low winter UV led to
not only extremely low
winter vitamin D levels,
but increased susceptibility
to HIV and TB infections.
This is something now that we are
continuing to work on.
The problem of lack of
vitamin D production
is now a problem, even if you don't have
darkly pigmented skin.
Lots of people with moderately
and lightly pigmented skin
are vitamin D deficient, simply
because they're not getting
outdoors very much, or
because they're very attentive
in their use of sunscreen.
These things are very important.
Protecting your skin against
ultraviolet radiation
is important.
We are long-lived animals.
We don't want our skin to deteriorate.
But we have to recognize
that if we're not getting
our vitamin D from the
sun, we have to get it
from some other sources.
And vitamin D deficiency is
now a serious global problem.
But what happens to this
other interesting molecule
in the skin that is produced
and released in great abundance
when the sun and ultraviolet radiation
impinges on the surface
of the skin, nitric oxide?
Recall that nitric oxide is released
in the skin by ultraviolet A radiation.
The release of nitric oxide in the skin
is made possible by our friend folate,
the B vitamin.
Nitric oxide is released in the skin
and it allows the peripheral
arteries to dilate,
thus providing fluid to
the eccrine sweat gland
so that we can maintain
thermal regulation.
And helping to control blood pressure.
What happens if people
are indoors all the time?
Nitric oxide isn't produced as much,
and vasodilation does not occur.
In fact, you can have
chronic vasoconstriction
under these circumstances.
And whether you have darkly
or lightly pigmented skin,
the problem is real.
Peripheral vasoconstriction as a result
of lack of sun exposure.
My colleague Richard
Weller at the University
of Edinborough, as well as
my colleague Larry Kenney
at Penn State University are
involved in studies looking
at the cardiovascular benefits of sunlight
that are independent of vitamin D.
And I am collaborating with
both of them very happily,
because I'm trying to figure
out how this all worked out
in evolutionary history,
and how it matters now to our health,
and why we have to pay
attention to the evolutionary
fundamentals in order
to lead healthier lives.
We evolved under the sun,
and the changes in our lifestyle
we have to think about very carefully.
The skin is our primary
interface with the environment.
It has been, it is no longer.
We need to sort of renegotiate.
We have to strike a new compromise
between behavior, diet, and culture
to improve health and well-being.
But do we go cry in our beer because,
oh woe is me, we have social problems.
We have color-based race problems.
We have health problems
related to skin color.
No, we don't despair,
because we are thinking humans
who prize education.
And one of the things I'm
involved in really happily
is the production of a
book that will be published
by David Philip Publishers
in Cape Town in July
about the evolution of skin pigmentation
for school kids in South Africa.
It will be initially be published in four
of South Africa's languages.
And by the end of the year
in the official 10 languages
of the country.
We can also, closer to home,
teach kids about diversity,
about human evolution, about
how all of this history
has played out and brought
us to where we are today.
This is possible.
This is a view from
one of the summer camps
that I have been running
with Henry Louis Gates, Jr
in the last few years in
a project that we call
the Finding Your Roots Project
and the Finding Your Roots summer camps.
We have brought together over 30 scholars
from Penn State and other institutions
into human geneticists,
education specialists,
bioethicists, historians,
many different folks,
to put together a curriculum, initially,
in formal science education,
middle school summer camps
where kids come and discover themselves.
We talk in this country not
only about problems of race,
but problems of inequity in education,
of problems of young individuals,
Latino, Native American, African American,
not going into science,
mathematics, engineering.
How can we improve these outcomes?
People have been beating
their head against many
good doors for years.
And we decided to try something
a little bit different.
And through this Finding
Your Roots curriculum,
as it now is funded by
the Robert Wood Johnson
and Rockefeller Foundations,
and also recently by private philanthropy,
we have the beginnings, I think,
of a mode of inquiry
that we can introduce,
not into universities,
not into high schools,
but into middle schools.
And just into informal contexts,
but into our classrooms.
This is exciting.
We can teach kids about themselves.
We can have them discover their own,
the wonder of their own DNA,
their unity to others by
looking at similarities
in their genomes.
Being with these kids is incredible.
Having them discover
things about themselves,
having them discover things
about lumbriculus worms
under the microscope,
about their ancestors
in the paleontology lab,
is very exciting.
And we leave them to conduct
their own experiments.
By the end of the summer
camp, they are scientists,
testing hypotheses themselves.
Having the confidence to investigate.
They are scrutinizing data,
talking about variability,
and yes in the United States,
we have kids talking about race,
and talking about why
people look differently,
and how race is a social construction
and what that means.
And when kids are 10, 11, 12 years old,
they aren't freighted with all
of the hangups of adulthood,
and it is marvelous to behold.
There is a lot of hope.
We may not be able to vaccinate
people against ignorance,
but we can use childhood education
as a form of vaccination
against antiquated views
on human diversity, human evolution,
race, and health.
There is lots of hope.
I want to thank very much the organizers
of this lecture series, for
this generous invitation,
thank my husband and primarily
collaborator George Chaplin,
who's in the audience today.
My superb research assistant Tess Wilson
for lots and lots of help.
Ellen Gobler who was
the logistic coordinator
for this series, tremendously.
Leslea Hlusko, tremendously
for the role that she played.
And another person who isn't
on the credits list here,
but Blake Edgar who is in the audience
who is my editor at the
University of California Press
who shepherded my two books,
popular books to press,
and who continues to be a
great guide and inspiration.
Many other people, many
foundations provide support for me.
I would be happy to send
you, if you write to me,
any number of publications, maps,
and other things that might interest you.
You might find some of them on my website.
I am always available.
Thank you very much for your attention.
(audience applauding)
- [Man] Dr. Jablonski,
that was really dynamic,
thank you so much.
As I mentioned yesterday,
my wife and I want to move
to University Park and sneak
into some of your lectures
so that we can hear more of you.
But my question is this.
As humanity continues to
move into urban areas,
as we continue to cover
ourselves with clothing,
not just our bodies but our head,
is the evolution, well from a,
natural selection perspective,
is our evolutionary
result going to be lighter skin?
- It's a very good question.
And the answer is pretty
simple in that there is,
we see no evidence of natural selection
promoting depigmentation now,
largely because there
is very little evidence
of people losing out
in the reproductive sweepstakes
as a result of living in cities
without sun exposure.
So there might be some,
if our epidemiological
studies were good enough,
we may be able to detect some signal
of sort of loss of fitness as a result
of urban lifestyles, but not
enough to promote changes
in gene frequency, leading
to changes in pigmentation.
But what we do see in urban environments
and this is one of the
beautiful parts of the Bay area,
literally, physically beautiful,
is that we see such lavish
admixture of people.
People from all different
parts of the world
come together, share
interesting cultural things,
have children together, and
produce new genetic combinations
and new phenotypes.
And often these phenotypes are lighter
than at least one of the parents.
So we aren't seeing
natural selection produce
loss of pigmentation.
But we are seeing sort of a mingling
and an increasing number of
pigmentation intermediates
being produced in many
urban centers in the world.
- [Man] I was fascinated
by your graph yesterday
of decreasing hair in our hominid line
in more recently thousand,
millions of years.
And that raises two questions that I wish
I had asked yesterday.
One is that, as I follow your discussion
of hairlessness and thermal regulation,
I wonder if actually losing hair
gave our ancestors
a flexibility to exploit
a much wider range
of environments than other primates
who had more hair.
In other words, a loss of
hair actually gave humans
a lot of flexibility to go into a lot
of very, very different environments.
And my second question
about hair is one thing
that we've noticed in nutrition
that if you're feeding
an animal like a mouse
or a rat that's full of hair,
you have different requirements
for sulfur-containing amino acids.
And I was wondering if there was actually
a nutritional component
in the loss of hair
in our own ancestry.
- Good questions.
In answer to the first, I
think much of human versatility
and our ability to disperse
and adapt to a wide range
of environments is due to
our incredible technology
and behavioral flexibility and
our incredible inventiveness,
which we have had since the
beginning of Homo sapiens
and probably even further.
When we look at the
cultural sophistication
of Neanderthals and
ancestors of Neanderthals
that were living over 200,000 years ago,
and modern humans in Africa
and outside of Africa
tens of thousands of years ago,
basically what you have
is a rich material culture
and a rich culture of the
mind that allows people
to live in places and under conditions
and following lifestyles that
other mammals cannot achieve.
So I think skin has played
a role in that it is
given us a different
mode of communication,
cutaneous communication,
communication through arraignment
as well as our body decoration,
has given us greater versatility.
We don't just have one outfit,
like you know, a dog or
a cat or a cow might have
just sort of one fur,
we have many.
So we're able to express
our individuality,
our group identity, through
how we adorn our naked bodies.
And I think that has
been part of the cultural
adaptation to different environments.
In connection with diet and hair,
the biggest things that
we notice in humans,
of course our gross protein deprivation
and the effects on hair
leading to hair breakage
and the conspicuous sort of red pigment
that you see in infants and
children with kwashiorkor.
Other nutritional benefits
are not that well understood
and there are all manners of diets
that people now subscribe
to for better hair,
making your hair more
luxurious, less kinky,
more wavy, what have you,
by eating certain foods.
The extent to which diet,
beyond providing basic
amino acids, the extent
to which modifying diet
is going to affect hair texture and curl
is really unclear.
So there's a lot of sort of
bad science and pseudoscience
about this, but I hope largely,
or partly through the work of
graduate students in my lab,
that we may be able to
understand some of these factors
a bit more in two to four years' time.
- [Woman] Hi, I actually
have a burning question.
- Please.
- If you could talk a little
bit more about the
difference between vitamin D3
and vitamin D2.
Because I'm really
curious about two things.
One is as we move to fortified milk,
and I actually don't now
much about the history
of when we did that and
what was the impetus
for doing it, how much of a health benefit
has that conferred?
And then also, is that
actually adequate to help
circumvent some of the
deleterious health effects.
- Really good questions.
Vitamin D2 is a form of vitamin D
that is produced primarily in plants.
When we ingest it, we can use it,
but it has to undergo and
additional hydroxylation step
in the liver.
So vitamin D3 is the more
common animal origin vitamin D,
although there is some
vitamin D3 in some plants,
but vitamin D2 is the more common.
Both of them are potentially usable,
but both of them when we ingest them
as food or as supplements, have to undergo
the rigorous conversion in
the liver, in the kidney,
and that final step of chemical
conversion in the kidney
to the active form of vitamin D,
that can occur from a
vitamin D2 or D3 precursor,
and that is the most
rate-controlled step in the body,
so that you can produce
a lot of vitamin serum D3
in its storage form,
but then the activation
to active D3 that occurs
in the kidney is extremely
highly controlled.
But these days, most
supplements are vitamin D3.
There are fewer of D2.
In answer to your question
about fortification in milk,
milk fortification was
introduced in this country,
widespread, after World War II
when the importance of vitamin
D in preventing rickets
in infants and children
was widely recognized.
And it was a public health remediation
that was initiated similar to that
of fluoridated water for the public good.
In this country, most milk that you buy
is vitamin D fortified.
But the amount of vitamin D
varies from one brand of milk
and even from one batch
of milk to the other.
The level of vitamin D fortification
is enough to prevent
the most severe level of deficiency,
but not to provide
physiological adequacy
for a child or an adult,
unless you drank
prodigious amounts of milk
that would be dangerous
from the point of view
of drinking too much calcium
and putting you at a
risk for kidney stones.
So the vitamin D3 fortification
in milk is very helpful
and could be used as a
model for other countries.
There are lots of places where milk is not
vitamin D fortified and
where this would help
to sort of lower the prevalence
of vitamin D deficiency
in some very vulnerable populations.
But that level of
fortification is not adequate
to meet physiological needs.
So one has to have other
vitamin D-rich foods,
of which there aren't very many.
Oily fish is the best source,
but there are few
genuinely oily fish around,
and so today, most people
really have to rely
on vitamin D supplements
and occasional prudent sun exposure.
- [Man] You timed your visit well.
You joined us in a sunny
interlude in an otherwise
very dark winter.
And that prompts my question.
I notice a lightening of the
mood when the sun is out.
And I wonder whether that
mood sensitivity to sunlight
could be related to a person's,
the location of the
evolution of their genotype.
- This is a great question,
and many people have been
interested in this in trying to understand
the biological basis and the genetic basis
for seasonal affective disorder,
and the role that vitamin D might play.
This is a fascinating
and complicated answer.
I'm gonna give you the short version.
What we have in our retinas of our eyes
are not only the three kinds of cones
that allow us to see beautiful
trichromatic color vision,
but we also have a
specialized subset of cones
that are blue light receptors.
So on a bright day like this,
there is a lot of very short
wavelength visible light
that stimulates the blue light receptors
that makes us more
alert, that communicates
with our pineal gland that communicates
with our pituitary gland
that communicates, sort of
the global endocrine switches
are turned on.
And many of these lead
to elevation of mood.
Beautiful work has been done comparing
the prevalence of seasonal
affective disorder
in places like Iceland versus Ecuador.
And what is found is that
there are real differences
in the amount of blue light
that stimulates the body,
and that this seems to be
one of the most important
arbiters of mood.
Vitamin D also contributes,
but interestingly it is not probably
the primary contributor to
seasonal affective disorder,
or the sort of the high that you feel.
Rather it's the stimulation
of your blue light receptors.
- [Man] I think milk was
the wrong thing to fortify,
because 50 million people in
the US are lactose intolerant,
and most African-Americans
are lactose intolerant.
So, we should figure out
what to put vitamin D in.
Now, I've been converting lots of people
to take vitamin D.
And if they're deficient,
they really feel terrific afterwards.
So there is, whether it's Danes,
I was in Denmark for a scientific meeting
and Denmark has, Copenhagen
has about the worst climate
in the world, at least
compared to Californians.
And it was a sunny day and
the whole city stopped.
Everybody had taken off
most of their clothes.
I must say more clothes were taken off
than an American would.
And there were all of
these half-naked bodies
all over the city all day.
Everybody was just,
nobody was in the shops,
nobody was doing anything but sunbathing.
I asked a Danish scientist friend,
"How come you do this?"
He said, "Well, we
Scandinavians get so little sun,
"that whenever there's sun, we sunbathe,
"because we feel terrific afterwards."
And I've had personal experience
with African-Americans
who I've gotten to take vitamin D,
and they feel terrific.
So I think that's something that'll help--
- Yes, and you know, in connection
with both of your points,
first of all, getting a vehicle
other than milk is important.
In South Africa there is fortification
of some margarine.
Unfortunately, you would
have to eat a huge amount
of margarine in order to benefit
from the vitamin D fortification.
One of the problems is that
vitamin D is oil-soluble,
so you can't easily sort of
put it into fortified cereals
or orange juice, although
people do put it into
the orange juice suspensions.
But it's a difficult molecule to deliver
in a fortification of a normal food.
But your point about Denmark
is a very interesting one,
because there they have
refused to fortify their milk.
So there is no baseline
fortification of milk
or any dairy products,
and people can only get
their vitamin D either from fish
or by taking off their clothes.
And they really, you
know you have sort of,
I don't want to impune the Danes at all,
but people sort of going to
their paleolithic sort of
past to expose themselves to sun.
And I think what's interesting there
is that when people are exposed to the sun
that their ancestors were used to,
you know if they gradually
sort of gain and lose
sun exposure or UV
exposure, their skin changes
and they're able to maintain
UV or vitamin D adequacy.
And in a country like Denmark,
when people were outside most of the time,
even though they had
vitamin D in their diet,
they got a lot of their
physiologically important
vitamin D throughout
the year from episodic,
but regular episodic sun exposure.
- [Man] They were also
eating a lot of fish.
- Yes, yes, much of which
doesn't exist anymore,
or is too expensive
for most people to buy.
- [Man] Now, vitamin D
isn't that expensive.
- Ah, it's here now, today,
in the United States, vitamin D is cheap.
You can go into any
supermarket, any health store,
get these huge bottles
for 10 bucks or less.
But go to Europe, go to South Africa,
and try to buy vitamin D.
It's not bulk processed there,
and a little bottle of 60 capsules
will cost you $20.
Or it'll cost you more
than that in South Africa
because it's imported from
the United States or Europe
and it's more than a week's wages.
- [Man] But at least in fortification
and telling people here,
you can buy vitamin D,
it's not that expensive.
- And I think, this is something where
the medical establishment
is moving significantly
and importantly to
recognize the importance
of vitamin D supplementation.
It's not the be all and the end all.
It's not a panacea by any means.
But raising people off
of baseline deficiency
will greatly improve health outcomes,
not only in the ways that I've described,
but in many others.
- [Man] You know, I've been
digging into that for years now
and there's a huge, I
think dark-skinned people
are carrying a big weight on their back.
And vitamin D is going to help.
- Yes.
- Well thank you, if you
have no more questions,
if we could do a big round of applause
and a thank you for Nina.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)